now the latest world press freedom index
has just been published and it paints a
mixed picture of countries across the
continent reporters without borders says
the situation in two countries egypt and
eritrea is extremely bad
egypt is described as one of the world's
biggest prisons for journalists and
eritrea has the second lowest ranking in
the world only north korea is worse some
african countries enjoy guaranteed press
freedoms they report highlights namibia
and south africa and africa's most
populous nation nigeria has a rich and
diverse media landscape but reporters
without borders says it is one of the of
west africa's most dangerous and
difficult countries for journalists who
are often watched attacked are
betrayally arrested
and even killed
now in 2020 dw's conflict zone spoke to
nigeria's minister of information lai
mohammed on the topic of press freedom
take a listen to what he said i i think
when it comes to
freedom of the press
we're doing extremely very well
if papers run foul
of the law
they must face the consequences but when
you have
virtually a hundred newspapers in the
country and you are citing the example
of one newspaper that was closer in a
year i think it should be fair to us
that we have a very robust free press my
next guest is a man who is well pleased
to tell us about the state of nigerian
press freedoms he is one of nigeria's
most talked about investigative
journalists david hundain welcome to dw
news africa now we just had the nigerian
information minister telling dw that the
country was doing extremely well when it
comes to press freedom that was two
years ago what's your experience today
as an award-winning investigative
journalist
experience is that i've had to flee the
country um
for the sake of my own personal safety
if i want to maintain my freedom and
possibly my life i simply cannot be in
nigeria i currently live under asylum
protection in exile in the country that
i'm
probably not allowed to to
name here so
um my experience has been completely at
odds with whatever it is that line
marmite has had to say and what i will
also mention is that even though um
we no longer have possible bombs being
delivered to journalists or you know uh
journalists getting uh
bullied in the newsrooms by soldiers you
know building ak-47 rifles in their
faces it doesn't mean that nigeria has a
free press in any way can you tell us
exactly what happened that made you flee
right so uh on the night of october 20
2020 the nigerian military carried out a
massacre of civilian unarmed civilian
protesters at the nikita plaza in lagos
state now i was
able to get access to information from
the mobile network provider which was at
the center of the brouhaha which
essentially implicated the nigerian
government
in terms of who who was responsible for
sabotaging its fiber optic cable
infrastructure because at the exact
moment that the massacre took place
people suffered mass internet outages so
for basically for putting this story out
there i knew that i was going to
potentially risk losing my freedom and
all my life so i fled the country before
putting the story out there
but on the face of it things look good
in nigeria right it has one of the most
diverse media landscapes on the
continent the constitution also protects
freedom of expression and opinion is
there nothing to celebrate you say so
nigeria has this thing called isomorphic
memory in developmental uh
economics so which means that on paper
it has
all the paraphernalia and appearances of
a functioning democratic society so as
you said it has constitutional guarantee
freedoms there's a freedom of
information act separation of powers all
that good stuff in practice the nigerian
government is by far and away the
largest median ad spender in nigeria
which means that even if they're not
pointing a gun in your face
just the simple fact that they wield the
purse strings makes it such that people
self-censor a lot
in the nigerian media space so yeah they
don't need to censor you directly you
will censor yourself
if you want to be able to pay you know
to make payroll next month now your west
africa weekly goes out on the
subscription platform
sub stack how much of a game changer are
online outlets like this
um what they have done is that they have
completely democratized
the flow of information because
the hyper independence of platforms like
west africa weekly has placed them
completely outside of the zone of
influence or control of any nigerian
public or private sector entity so
essentially um that makes in the
nigerian government's eyes that makes us
very dangerous because west africa for
example has a subscriber base of just
over 21 000 as at last week and a total
global distribution list of in the
region of 100 000 plus so there's a
large audience for it and this is
essentially media that is not controlled
in any way by nigerian government it's
not funded even with money that comes
from nigeria in any way so that's from
the point of view of of
objective unbiased press is good news
but from the point of view of the
nigerian government is probably very bad
news indeed so um you won the 2020
people's journalism prize for informed
commentary and you've been a trailblazer
for independent media but you have more
enemies than you've won awards clearly
do you still have hope that things can
change for the better in your home
country
um yeah i do and i think when things
will change for the better is when
um more nigerians develop a sort of
political consciousness
about what exactly
the interaction is between things like
freedoms and economics and the elections
that they participate in very
rambunctiously every four years because
currently there's a sort of disconnect
people don't really seem to be able to
link the electoral choices they make
with the outcomes like the lucky
massacre or bullying of journalists or
you know flatlining economy so i feel as
if as people become more informed don't
forget that the internet is still pretty
much a new space in nigeria most
nigerians didn't have
basically internet access until maybe
around 2010 2011.
so
the country is just maybe like a decade
old in terms of access to information so
i think
over as time goes on as people mature as
more and more as nigerian society
becomes more information saturated i
think naturally people's political
consciousness will start to evolve and
the country will start to make progress
kicking and screaming yes
okay david hyundain investigative
journalist in nigeria thank you
thanks for having me